Here's your coffee.
Hey, man, I just have
to say, I am a huge fan.
Outkast, like,
changed my life.
Yeah, yeah.
Thanks, man.
So are you gonna collaborate
with André 3000 again?
Nah.
How come?
People grow apart.
Greetings.
May I have a half-caff
decaf mint mocha latte,
foam on the bottom,
served in a flower vase,
and if y'all got
some green food coloring
back there, throw it in.
André 3000!
In the flesh.
Big Boi is right over there.
- [gasping dramatically]
- Big Boi!
Bitch, I'm trying
to read a book.
Big Boi!
What's up, my brother
from another mother, man?
Hey, when I say mother, you know
I'm talking about art, right,
'cause we got cut out of
her womb linked together.
What's up, man?
What's up, André?
André who?
I ain't gonna say it, man.
It's not 2,999.
It's not 3,001.
- André 3000.
Hey, man, what happened
to you after the show?
Yeah, um.
I just--I must have, like, snuck
out or something like that.
[in English accent]
I thought perchance
you went missing.
Don't do the voices, man.
Do what voice, my dear boy?
Why do you--why do you
got to do the voices, man?
Why you doing the voices?
Why you doing that, man?
One green half-caff half
decaf mint mocha latte,
foam on the bottom,
in a vase?
I got a new idea
for a album, man.
It's gonna be just the sound
of screeching metal,
and then only one
spoken word per track.
- Cool, cool.
- Yeah.
[high pitched squeals]
That's my new screeching
metal sounds
I was talking about
earlier, man.
One green half-caff half
decaf mint mocha latte,
foam on the bottom,
in a vase or "vahz."
You ain't hear?
That--that's your--
nig--that's--
you the only nigga
that ever order that drink.
Yeah, okay, so what
is going on with me?
What is happening with me?
Man, what the fuck
happened, man?
- What are you talking about?
- We used to be somebody, man.
We used to be a team.
We was on top.
Then you went
and lost your fucking mind.
Can we just lose this, man?
Can we just lose the 3000
and just have you talk as André?
Tell me--tell me straight up,
man, what happened?
You know what be even
better, though, man?
Is if you looked into the
pinwheel with your third eye.
I thought you was gonna say
some stupid shit like that.
And everything
will be revealed.
All right, man.
It's been good, man, thank you.
- Thanks for coming by, man.
- Okay, yeah.
Matter of fact, I got
an appointment right now
to go get fitted for a toga.
- You got--you got to go.
- Mm-hmm.
You leaving me.
That's a...
Don't do it.
May Eros, Artemis,
and Apollo
guide you through
your musical journey.
Nigga, what?
Why does your breath smell
like birdseed?
- Au revoir.
- All right.
Thank you, café craftsman.
You're welcome.
Sweedoop poops.
Sweden dweeps.
Sweep boop dweeps.
Sweden dweep.
Sorry, he--he didn't actually
pay for that drink.
I got it.
♪ Yeah ♪